so it's the night of the British
Independent Film Awards tell me are you
excited to be here
yeah I'm absolutely buzzing I'm so
excited honestly I can't really describe
have a feel just so you know I'm trying
to keep my math Jesus grand down a
little but we'll see what happens
it's good to be happy yes yes good to be
off but you live longer if you're happy
yeah
now tell me a bit about your role in the
Angels share and well my role as
basically about a young lad who is
commits a president he strikes on his
life around and he falls in love with a
beautiful girl or an event that he is
find yourself doing community service
and basically there's a character John
Henshaw we play sorry he's like a father
figure so between the both of them
they're drinking whiskey Robby alone so
it taste and smell and noise Wes key and
comes up a cunning plan to do a heist
but and between that all he's really
want to do is get a job he's just
working that job to support his family
he's what changed and it's about the
places of you know a society of people
and young people and how Robbie deals of
that and it's a real powerful story tell
me a little bit about another film
you've got coming up as well because not
only of you had this bond which of
course you've been nominated for here
tonight but you've also been working
with Scarlett Johansson I write and gets
it yeah tell me a little bit about that
every guy's dream
yeah I was under I skin that so next
year actually why I was I was a
fantastic job I was really nervous
you know I remember the first time I met
her was introduced her and I forgot why
even she can hand that was out in the
nervous I was like and I walked to me in
a [ __ ] what we're done F what [ __ ]
but you know what I was fading she was a
lovely girl I had a fantastic time on
that joint families as a fantastic
director you know just a normal guy for
me just talk to normal guy very
laid-back and we had a great team on it
and no Borden I'm doing sunshine on
Leith yeah of course you know gonna be
sure big hit as the stage show has been
as well we've found of that are you find
the Proclaimers oh yeah my fine I
typically most especially if you're
gonna pop in your Abbey but you know
everybody likes a Proclaimers about I'm
looking forward to us having a fertile
or you know good days on and new
experiences and learning a lot so is
that already in the can for you or that
coming up you know that's that might not
just know what cannot not just know what
kind of things you enjoying being on set
for that at the moment just just keen to
learn and who is saying and having fun I
hang out so I can really see them warm
with you enjoying the singing is it
something you'd not really tackle before
do you know what was worried the boat up
and then when I done my foster - it and
they said to me it actually quite good
and then we've done some voice coaching
and it's just it's just kept on just
kept on from there you could see more
singing roles in the future do you think
yeah yeah thanks thanks or maybe an old
grease number or something see you
happens what we do you look forward to
doing that exhaust isn't randomly and I
would just like to do something really
really challenging again to know
something that's physically mentally
emotionally you know I like to do stuff
like that I like to get really an ear
something that's I can tap any of my
emotions and show real you know Frank my
real experience ease to the floor and
then believe it when we're done you know
what I love olive do not when you do
those kind of quite intense roles is it
difficult to lead them in the studio or
on say at the end of the day well not
from me not from you for me is for me I
Frank you know I'm a life experience
carries me through that anyway so I just
you know I was just I just thinking
about my emotions I think about stuff
that's you know I've been through in the
past and I just playing into the floor
then I'll ever you know once lying on an
off switch which I'm a fortunate to have
no no I mean I was and I was like I
might call it's just knowing that
they're trying to teach me and I'm like
you can't teach this well I've got you
know I'm not being
like you can't teach someone a tap on
emotions that no so yeah unfortunately
as Dexter Fletcher he was directing at
the moment in those terms it's famous
hyper its hey sorry it's just this mad
as a brush great guys but you know what
he says he's a really sorry oh privilege
to be working my from actually you know
because he's doesn't often make every
advice and in the faculty he's an actor
itself and also you feel you knows how
I'm feeling as a young you know a young
lad young actor trying to make it
through and it gives me all the support
on it you know what Phil crew and
casters so happy or not
you